those fans have something to praise the
sun about today as a release date has
been announced for dark souls 3 for
japan at least from software have
announced that the game will arrive in
japan on march 24 of next year for xbox
one and ps4 previously the game had only
been slated for a vague early 2016
release window komatsu have reported
that a Western release date and launch
date for the piece the addition will be
announced in the coming days the games
website also indicates that the Dark
Souls 3 retail edition will come with a
specially designed in that and
soundtracks change pen from software
have also announced that a network test
for the ps4 edition of Dark Souls 3 is
going to be held from October 16 to 18
if you want to join in you can find a
link to the sign up page in a story on
gamespot Bandai Namco have said that
while dark souls 3 will bring certain
story elements to a conclusion it isn't
necessarily the final game in the series
and I namco actually recently
trademarked a bunch of new names
including flashy souls so you can make
about what you will let me know down in
that comment bus if you'll be playing
dark souls 3 and for all the biggest
stories in gaming be so stay tuned to
games but